Have you ever been in need of
a tool that you didn't have?
Imagine that you have this
screw that you need to unscrew,
but you don't have the right
screwdriver to do that.
So what do you do?
Go to the nearest
hardware store.
You look at the
various screwdrivers.
They have bigger, smaller,
different screw heads.
You pick the one that
will match your screw.
You bring it home.
You unscrew.
You're good.
Some time passes.
You want to find
a table that will
match the space between
your sofa and the wall?
But you don't have a measuring
tape, and you need one.
So what do you do?
We go to the nearest
hardware store.
Look at the various
measuring tapes they have.
Longer, shorter.
Thinner, wider.
Start wondering why
that even matters.
But you need to make a decision.
So we pick one.
Bring it home.
Measure. You're good.
Some time passes.
You need to hammer a nail.
So what do you do?
Start wondering,
wouldn't it make sense
to buy a complete
toolbox instead
of assembling one tool by tool?
My name is Kamil.
I'm an full-stack
engineer at Appsilon.
We specialize in building
Shiny applications.
Let me tell you of
a typical situation
that we faced many
times over in our work.
So a client comes to
us and asks whether we
could build an
application for them.
Using wonderful
capabilities of Shiny,
we create something
within a couple
of hours that is interactive
and impresses the client.
Contract signed.
The project starts.
Couple of weeks pass.
The codebase grows
20 times and we realize
that we are spending a lot
of time discussing the code
style, where the opening
brackets should be.
We figure that we need some
tools that will automatically
check this for us.
We need a linter.
So what do we do?
We find lintr, we
configure it properly,
we add it to the project.
We start linting our code.
We are good.
Some time passes.
We realize that we touch
one place in the application
and something else breaks.
So we figured that we
should start writing tests.
We need unit tests.
What do we do?
We find testthat.
We configure it.
We add it to the project.
We start writing unit tests.
We're good.
Some time passes and you get
the point. Needs keep arising
and we need to keep
addressing them.
We start wondering,
wouldn't it make sense
to start with a complete
development toolbox
instead of assembling
one tool by tool?
This goes deeper, though, in
case of development tools.
Introducing them later
on in the project
is typically more costly.
For example, if you want to
add lintr when you already
have hundreds of lintr errors,
you first have to fix them all.
And that's not
only a lot of work,
but you need to synchronize
it with your team.
But we should take even a
wider perspective, though.
It's not just one project.
It's multiple teams dealing
with multiple projects
at the same time.
And similar needs arise
in each of those projects,
and each team keeps
configuring the same tools.
Wouldn't it be wonderful to
have just one universal toolbox?
All this effort
could be directed
into really polishing it instead
of reinventing the wheel all
the time.
Moreover, in an
organization when
you have just one
universal toolbox,
people get proficient using it.
So when you start a new project
or move to a different one,
everybody is up to speed
right from the beginning.
This can really bring
the productivity
to a whole new level.
So you can see what kind
of problem we have here.
And this is where my personal
story begins, right here
in the middle.
So I joined Appsilon
two years ago in July.
It was a hot month.
My brother was coming.
It was the last month of
our only office being open.
Pandemic was raging.
Lots of things were happening.
So my first project was
called project patterns.
What was that?
Well, technically speaking,
it was a Git repository
with snippets of code on
branches and the related Python
tool that could be
used to combine them
into project structure for
new and existing projects.
Sounds complicated.
It was.
And it was my task
to improve it.
So, first of all,
I try to understand
the purpose of all this.
And I started
researching what we try
to do about this in the past.
And it turned out that we
did a lot. Like years before,
already we had
discussion groups and we
had a repository
of code snippets
that could be reused
to some extent.
Directly before
project patterns,
we had something
called we had set up
involving RStudio in
Docker and the related bash
tool that could be used to
automate some of the things.
So I realized that already
many people before me
tried to solve these
problems that we had,
and I had the week
to improve that.
You can guess that I didn't
manage to fix everything
within that week, but for
the following two years,
we kept improving what we had.
For example, we went through
a phase of simplification
where instead of having all
this complex set of tools,
we created just a simple Shiny
template, a Git repository that
could be cloned and used as
a basis for your project.
We also researched other tools.
For example, we took
a look at gollem.
We tried to learn how it
differs from our approach.
We try to learn from it.
We've considered whether
we could just use it.
So for two years, we
kept addressing the needs
as they were arising, resolving
issues as they were surfacing.
And finally, in year
2022, we started
feeling that we have
something that we
want to share with the world.
And thus, Rhino was born.
No, not this rhino.
Rhino the free and
open source R package,
which we announced in May this
year during Appsilon Shiny
conference.
So it's an R package, means
it has functions, for example,
this rhino init function.
It creates a new
rhino project for you.
So what do we get inside?
Perhaps the most obvious part
is the full project structure
of files and directories.
So we have places for
configuration, source files,
dependencies, tests, everything
is covered from the beginning.
So let's take a deeper
look at some of those.
Any project will need other
R packages to do its job.
And it's very important
to be explicit about what
these other packages are
and what versions you need.
If you are not
explicit about that,
you might find that
when you try to launch
a project after a couple
of months, it doesn't work.
Why?
Who knows?
Maybe some package
got updated and it broke.
If you have an explicit
list of dependencies,
the chances that it will
just work are much higher.
And we have renv
package to deal
with this. For a similar issue,
but related to R
sources themselves,
we have the box package.
This one allows you to
use Python style imports
at the top of each file.
So that for each file
it is immediately
obvious what packages, functions
and other files it needs.
So moving on to the
quality of our code,
we have three
packages which deal
with that. For writing tests,
We have testthat package.
Then we have lintr
which can be used to
automatically test
the style of your code and also
detect some errors that you
might have.
And we have the
styler package which
is able to fix many of those
problems automatically.
All these tools can be run using
Rhino functions out of the box.
You don't need to
configure anything.
Just do, for example,
rhino lint R,
and you get your code linted.
So in enterprise
settings, typically you
will have some needs that
will be quite common.
For example, one
of them is logging.
It is very important to
output good log messages
from your application.
If it breaks, for
example, in production,
this kind of log
messages can really
help you to find
what the issue is.
And we have the logger
package which deals with that.
Then you typically will have
more than one environment.
You will have the local one
when you develop
the application,
Then, you will have staging
where you will be testing it
before pushing it to
production. And to manage
the differences between
these different environments,
we have the config package.
Now in any big project, we
realize that sooner or later we
need JavaScript.
We need to customize the
application beyond what's
provided by R packages.
And we figured, why not use the
state of the art tech for that?
So for JavaScript, we will
run your code through Babel
and webpack this
to ensure that you
can use the latest
features without worrying
about browser support.
We have ESLint that
you can use to check
the quality of your
JavaScript code
and also fix many of the
errors automatically.
While these things need Node.js
to be installed on your machine
when using it from
Rhino, you
will just call the
package functions build js,
lint js. Now similarly,
we typically
need to add some custom styling.
And we chose Sass to do that.
It's an extension
for the CSS language
which allows you to
structure your code in a more
maintainable and better way.
And again, here to
compile your Sass
into something understandable
by the browser,
we use the state of the art
latest implementation of Sass.
We also have style lint which
is able to lend your style
files automatically.
Now, what else do you
need in a big project?
Well, certainly more testing.
And as we already
are using node.js,
we are using also
Cypress for end to end
testing of your application.
This framework allows you to
launch your whole application,
interact with it like
press buttons, type text,
and then verify if it
behaved as expected.
For example, that some text
appeared or window got opened.
So again, this
can be used simply
by running a function of the
package called test and to end.
And finally, as a cherry
on top automation,
all these tools are useless
if you are not actually
running them.
And if it's not
happening automatically,
sooner or later, you will
probably forget about it.
So if you use GitHub,
Rhino comes
with a working out of the box
set up for GitHub Actions.
This will run all
the linters, unit
tests, end to end tests for
you automatically once you
initialize your project.
All right.
So to summarize, what is Rhino?
Well, certainly you can think of
it as this complete development
toolbox with all
those things that
have just listed and mentioned.
But it's more than that.
We call it a framework.
And if you know other frameworks,
go for Python or Ruby on rails.
We took a slightly
different angle here.
While you do get the
project structure packages
to use and basic structure
for your application,
we also have all
these tools around it
for ensuring the
quality of your code.
So we can think of
Rhino as a framework,
but for the whole
development process.
Then Rhino is certainly the
Appsilon way to do things.
It is an opinionated framework
based on years of experience
that we have in building
Shiny applications.
It is not the only
way to do things,
but it is the way
that we believe in
and that we recommend.
And finally, Rhino is
great for enterprise.
While you can certainly use it
in your next proof of concept
project that you
will show to nobody.
Its benefits really start
to shine in organizations
when you have this one
universal toolbox, which
everybody can use.
It really can bring your
productivity to a new level.
So I hope this got you a
bit interested in Rhino.
Perhaps maybe even
somewhat excited.
So if that's the case,
all you need to do
is to go to our website.
It contains an extensive
documentation for the package,
as we believe it is an essential
part of a framework like this.
So thank you for
listening and I encourage
you to use Rhino
in your next project.